six and ten with a five point zero four
e r a for zach he's been a lot better in
the daytime than he has that night
swinging a miss and a strikeout good
start for davies
the first two just get going here in
wrigley
and fell tipped into the middle roman
struck him out good start for zach
davies rockies go one two three
end of a half minute colorado nothing
here come the cubs this would be the
22nd start this year for austin nine and
seven 103 strikeouts 1-0 on schwendell
and this ball is in the air toward left
center field hilliard joe look out oh
man he's got it still
he caught the ball
he is down on the ground and
he's in some pain that was a
unbelievable
collision and somehow connor held on to
the baseball now he's on his feet wow
that curveball's lined and caught by
rogers
with one out cj crone will be coming up
he swings at the 3-0 and sends it high
in the air to center field to the wall
goes ortega it is gone
touch him all times cj crone
his eighth homer here in august his 22nd
of the year
one nothing rockies just a torrid month
for cj krone and a good sign he's been
really strong at coors field but he gets
the road home run so here's david bodie
colorado native to one
he drills
so he comes up with the equalizer 1-1
of body bomb
yeah that was kind of down towards the
end of the battle a little bit and uh
strong young man and a little helping
breeze here this afternoon warm day ball
carries
this ball lied to center field base hit
and dom nunez coming home no throw from
ortega rogers comes through and the
rockies have a 2-1 lead in the third so
how big was that movement on the 2-2
pitch for dom nunez
two on
here's the 02.
good slider yeah really good slider
we've seen
that particular slider now produce a
couple of strikeouts he got andrew
romine
in a similar
locale got him on a breaking ball now
this lighter has been uh gompers best
friend today
four strikeouts now
2-2 on wisdom he goes back foot slider
what a job by gobber he gives up a soft
hit to davies and then hermeso in the
middle of the lineup two on no one out
and he gets three straight punch outs
well done austin gobert
davies gets him to swing and miss a
strikeout story
over two
swinging a miss
good start to the inning
for davey's two away the pitch
[Applause]
moving ground ball left of the mound
bare-handed by davies who slings it to
first in time to get mcmahon another 3-2
coming up on bodhi
and he got him on a slider
that slider has been gobber's best
friend this afternoon six strikeouts
four in a row for austin yeah all on
sliders every strikeout today 2-1
oh this ball's well hit to right and
charlie's got it right in front of the
ivy
romine singled his last time up in the
second the o2
romine swings and hits one in the air to
deep left this one is gone at the corner
for a home run a line drive down the
left field line that leaves the yard and
romine ties up the game at two bromine
goes out and hooks this breaking ball
and just keeps it fair by about i don't
know three or three feet or so
but a line drive bullet down the line a
curve ball and you're just waiting with
the way the wind is blowing in from
right is it gonna stay fair but he hit
it hard enough where the wind really
didn't mess with it much and just a line
drive rocket into the first row of seats
and the bleachers down the line
2-2 on andrew romond
and he got him on a change-up that is
strikeout number seven
wanted back to the mound davies
sacrifice executed making a move right
here
he's going to take the baseball
from davies
cody hoyer now
on the ground to third
duffy handles and throws them out good
job by hoyer
[Applause]
this is lifted to center field shallow
center field brennan rogers will make
the catch
and another slider on the inside part of
the plate may have missed location a
little bit with that but he still gets
the strikeout that's eight now for
gomber they're at the corners and an
opportunity
for patrick wisdom and now the 1-1 from
gomber drilled in the air
deep left field get out the tape measure
long gone
patrick wisdom a three-run homer cubs
lead five to two
that ball is absolutely crushed
down the line and left that is a no
doubter the only issue was fair or
foul it was a breaking ball he got all
of it
way on the wavelength avenue it may have
landed across the street
and left-handed bat stacked up here for
the rocky so the lefty comes out of the
bullpen morgan takes his time
slowly comes set
and delivers 3-2 swinging a pop fly this
should be out number one beauty at
second coming in calling and making the
catch
one down here in the seventh inning
cubs lead 5-2 and the batter now is ryan
mcmahon
excellent pitch just to get the little
pop-up from morgan that's a little back
door breaking ball and krone has to
reach out and just pops it up
left details
absolutely back to the mound morgan
morgan deals
[Music]
in the
and fittingly enough it ends in the
glove of the guy that had the big hit
patrick wisdom
you